اهلا بك نايف اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بدا المسافرين الصينيين
وتحديدا الرعايه الصينيين الكان القادمين
من بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بعد عمليات اجلاء قامت بها
السلطات السعوديه الى مدينه جدها هم اليوم
يستعدون لاستقلال هذه الطائره الضخمه التي
تسمى بتربل بوينج تربل 7 سوف تقوم بنقل
300 وتسعه وسبعين شخص من الرعايه الصينيين
الذين وصلوا الى جده بعد عمليات لجنه قامت
بها السلطات السعوديه بالتنسيق مع الحكومه
الصينيه وصل حتى هذه اللحظه الى المطار
قرابه الميتين الشخص وهم يصلون على دفعات
متقطعه حتى يكتمل عدد تم شحن الحقائب
والعفشه الخاص بهؤلاء الرعايه في انتظار
فقط اكتمال وصول الاعداد وانهاء اجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات وكذلك اداره الجمارك من ثم
التوجه الى هذه الطائره تريبل
في رحله تستغرق 10 ساعات من مطار الملكه
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده الى مطار العاصمه
الصينيه بكين في ظرف عشره ساعات اثناء تم
استقبالها هؤلاء الرعايه الصينيين من قبل
ممثلين دبلوماسيين وكذلك عدد من المسؤولين
في السفاره الصينيه وكذلك موظفين واداريين
من اداره مطارات اجده للتسهيل مهمه هؤلاء
الرعايه من متوقع انه او سوف تقلع هذه
الطائره في تمام الساعه الثالثه والنصف
ظهرا بتوقيت السعوديه سوف تتجه الى
العاصمه الصينيه بكير بعد اكتمال وصول
كامل الى عدد نتحدث عن وجود
379 شخص من الرعايه الصينيين اكدوا لنا
مسؤولين في السفاره الصينيه انه هؤلاء
الاعداد او 379 شخص هم كافه الرعايه الذين
تم اجلائهم حتى هذه اللحظه من بورت سودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ومن ثم
سكنهم بجده من المتوقع وصول اعداد اخرى
خلال اليومين القادمين قادمين من
بورتسودان بعد بعد عمليه الاجلاء التي سوف
تقوم بها القوات البحريه السعوديه بتنسيق
مع الخارجيه السعوديه
والسفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره
379 شخص سوف تقول لهم هذه الطائره
مباشره الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين في ظرف
عشر الساعات ايضا نتحدث عمليات الاجلاء لا
تزال مستمره الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده والى كذلك الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه بجده وكذلك عبر او الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي ايضا يتحدث انه المتوقع غدا وصول
1600 شخص عبر السفينه مدنيه الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه تحمل على متنها قرابه
الالف شخص بمختلف جنسياتهم كما اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان لها صادر
خلال الساعات السعوديه قامت باجلاب
2991 من 80 جنسيه اجنبيه مختلفه لذلك
نتحدث انه عمليات الاجلاب لا تزال مستمره
من السودان وتحديدا من ميناء بورتسودان
الى مدينه جده ونتحدث هنا للرعايه الصينيه
سوف يكونوا من اول الرعايه الذي سوف
يستقلون الطائرات بعد انتهاء اجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم في مدينه جده وصولا الى
عاصمتهم الصينيه بكين المتوقع ايضا سوف
تكون هنالك ايضا رحلات جويه اخرى من مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده لرعايه
لجنسيات مختلفه خلال اليومين القادمين
ماذا عن الرحلات القادمه من البورتسودان
عبر البحر سلطان والتي يعني ستقدم الى
السعوديه هل من معلومات عنها هذا اليوم
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى استقبل الرصيف
البحري الخاص بقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده سفينتين تابع للقوات البحريه
السعوديه وهي سفينه جلاله الملك مكه
وسفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل نتحدث من
السفينه الجبيل على متنها 52 شخص من 14
جنسيه وفيما يتعلق بسفينه مكه كان على
متنها
395 شخص من 18 الجنسيه جميعهم وصلوا الى
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى تم استقباله من ممثلين
الدبلوماسيين وسفراء بلدانهم لانهاء كافه
الاجراءات وكذلك تم استقباله من قيادات من
القيادات الخاصه بقوات البحريه وتم انهاء
كافه الاجراءات الخاصه بهم ونقلهم عبر
حافلات الى مقرات السكن الخاصه به حتى يتم
انهاء الاجراءات المتعلقه بالسفر لبلدانهم
خلال اليومين الماضيه عبر مطار الملك
عبدولي هنا بجده
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات